the Joe Rogan experience by the way I
got through the laundry series on I
still haven't watched a Netflix
documentary on your boy that looks
exactly like so much but god damn dude
that wand REE podcast series warriors
some good so good I was gripped it was
one of those you know sometimes you get
a podcast series like that like another
one is the drop out about that Elizabeth
Holmes chick that robbed everybody with
that theranos that's right that's
another one is it good there's a few of
those we start I mean you're like what
the [ __ ] dude sometimes I'll sit in my
car and wait till episodes done its I'm
like so into it I'm on something right
now that I know you're you're you read
you've got chaos book the Charles Manson
my ass bro he's coming in who humm
O'Neill's coming in next week
yes I'm in the middle of that book right
now oh holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] you'll get
mad a little different you'll get the
whole thing a little different yes like
what yeah I don't wanna see too much cuz
I want Tom to explain when you having
him on next week that books so [ __ ]
good
dude I'm balls deep in there I mean
right now rave about that book for a
grip well what the things are absolutely
provable that he knows Charles Manson
the CIA in the secret history of the
sixties the the things that are
absolutely 100 percent provable just
those things are mind blowers were you
like whoa and it's documented huh how
the CIA in the SD house and in
haight-ashbury in San Francisco and yeah
how he was doing wild ship and the CA
would let him go
yeah or how he was out here at that
ranch and the cops never people would go
dude he's doing wild [ __ ] arrest them
like we're told not to touch him like
what yeah [ __ ] they killed the caretaker
that ranch didn't find that guy's body
until the late 70s yeah they they did a
lot of my favorite books it's a very
good book they did a lot of [ __ ] in the
1970s with drugs and people for
experiments in 60s and the 70s and
that's how they created the Unabomber
and Ted Kaczynski was a part of the
Harvard LSD program yeah what did you
watch that documentary the net not the
one you saw it's on Netflix which one is
it I forget but it's about the Unabomber
at night I didn't know that I'm like why
is he such why was he so [ __ ] up
Manhunter
I think so yes it's so good there's
another one
what's the other one called oh that's
why Unabomber in his own so it's the
first time he let one person ever
interview him and it's all the tapes
from the interview and you know his
legal his defense team goes listen dude
you're not gonna get the death penalty
if you just plead insanity goes I'm not
insane he was do I seem insane to you he
was I'm not insane and so he fired his
defense team because they wanted to say
it was insane your's I'd rather die than
be called insane he's like I'm not
insane I'm a genius dude he was smart as
[ __ ] well he might be too smart because
he's actually looked he's not correct to
kill those people but he is correct that
technology is eventually going to
overcome people
[Applause]